imagine a soldier the size of an insect
the ultimate secret weapon you give that
like powers to everyone it's gonna be
chaos so how do we stop them by knowing
hi
Scot I've been watching you for a while
you're different and I believe everyone
deserves a shot at redemption do you
absolutely my days of breaking into
places and stealing stuff are over
what do you want me to do I want you to
break into a place and steal some stuff
make sense are you ready to become the
hero now this suit has power
you have to learn how to control it
and these are you greatest allies you're
kind of cute when you're small you have
superhuman strength
you like a bullet
so you need to know how to punch you
know you said we had a bunch show me how
to punch that's how you punch you tried
to hide your suit from me
now it's gonna blow up in your face and
destroy everyone care about
get out of here
did you think you could stop the future
you're just a thief
man man I know wasn't my idea
you